network intelligence center is Google
cloud solution for network monitoring
across the cloud and on-premise it
improves user experience security and
operations by providing a comprehensive
platform for monitoring visualizing and
troubleshooting network health across
the cloud and data center connectivity
test is a module in network intelligence
center that enables you to do network
verification which is a key part of
intent-based networking the idea of
verification is to ensure that the
intent of the network designer is being
met it also allows you to move from
reactive to proactive network operations
by predicting what could happen when you
make a config change thus preventing
network outages published sources show
that 75% of network outages and
performance issues happen due to mis
configuration in a complex Google cloud
environment with shared VPC many
firewall rules and routes it can be
difficult to quickly identify which
configuration caused the connectivity
issue connectivity test enables a user
to test connectivity between a source
and destination endpoint it also tells
you if the connectivity is broken and
identifies the root cause such as a
firewall rule or route config
connectivity test performs a static
reachability analysis by building a
model of the network and then doing
packet simulation on the network based
on configuration let's see how you can
use on-demand connectivity tests with
the help of three different examples say
you've run into connectivity issues
between two VM instances in different
zones in a project you can check the
connectivity between source and
destination endpoint by creating a
connectivity test click on create
connectivity test pick the protocol ICMP
select a source VM instance or an IP
address pick VP c1 us VM and a
destination VM instance slash IP address
pick V PC 1 EU VM and click create this
saves the test and also runs it once the
test is run it shows test result as
unreachable click on view to check the
result details it shows you a detailed
hop-by-hop trace showing how the packet
would traverse through the network from
the trace you can see the packet starts
from the source vm goes through an
egress firewall rule and then the packet
gets dropped by the ingress firewall
rule at the destination VM you can click
any of the hops to see more details of
the hop here if you click ingress
firewall rule you can see that the deny
ICMP firewall rule blocked the
connectivity right from here you can go
to the firewall rule page update or
disable the firewall rule let's disable
the firewall rule and check if this
fixes the issue select the test and run
the connectivity test again to verify
the impact of your firewall rule change
and make sure connectivity is restored
after you rerun the test results shows
reachable which tells you that the
connectivity issue is fixed notice how
easy it was to quickly understand the
trace find out the root cause firewall
rule and update it and analyze whether
it fixes the problem let's look at a
more complex scenario where there are 2
v pcs connected via high availability
VPN age a VPN creates two tunnels to
provide four nines of availability will
test connectivity between a VM and V PC
one connected to a VM and V PC to via
hav p.m. click on create connectivity
test and pick the protocol TCP source
and destination VM
and click create it shows test result as
unreachable click on view to see the
trace in this case you can see there are
two traces which is expected since this
path is through H a VPN connectivity
test will show you multiple traces if
they exist from this trace you can see
that there is a VPN gateway and the
traffic is getting dropped at the
ingress firewall role VPC to deny HTTP
you can go to the firewall rules page
and fix or disable the firewall rule
let's disable it and rerun the test and
you can now see that the connectivity is
restored you can also check the second
trace to analyze the path and make sure
both the tunnels are set up correctly
[Music]
you can also verify connectivity between
Google Cloud and on-prem or on Prem to
Google Cloud which could be especially
useful during application migration here
we are checking the connectivity between
the VM instance on GCP and an external
on Prem IP address click on create
connectivity test select protocol ICMP
[Music]
source beyond incidents as VP c1 us BM
and destination IP address once the test
finishes you can see test result shows
reachable which means the connectivity
is OK you can click on view and look at
the path trace to better understand your
network design in this case you can see
the trace is going through a NAT gateway
and can reach the external IP address as
a user you can create and save multiple
connectivity tests that reflect your
intent connectivity that should be
allowed and those that should be blocked
here you can see we have created and
saved a few different tests anytime you
make a configuration change you can run
these tests to verify the impact of your
configuration changes for some tests the
intent might be to have connectivity
between the endpoints so you'll see
those test results in green for other
tests the intent might be to block
connectivity between the endpoints so
those test results should be in red
anytime you make a configuration change
you can run these tests to make sure
your intent stays intact connectivity
test provides you a quick way to do
network verification and ensure that any
configuration change does not violate
your intent it allows you to treat your
configuration as code and you can think
of these as unit tests that you can run
to prevent network outages and also
verify your security / compliance
posture congratulations you are all set
up to start using the connectivity test
module in network intelligence center to
do network verification quickly diagnose
connectivity issues due to miss
configuration and predict the impact of
configuration changes
[Music]